guten nachmittag herr post die
allererste frage ist natürlich warum
haben sie ihr t shirt verbrannt was was
war der gedanke hinter ihrer aktion
na ja der gedanke hinter meiner aktion
war natürlich eine unvorstellbare gut
dass ein dax-konzern die er in seiner
letzten veröffentlichten bilanz noch
einen kassenbestand von 870 millionen
euro ein ein bilanzgewinn von 705
millionen euro ausgewiesen hat sich
jetzt ausgerechnet auf unsere kommune
not gesetze beruft die eben dafür da
sind dass man unternehmen hilft die
wirklich auf grund der kubakrise kurz
vor einer insolvenz stehen
es gibt auf keinen fall eine grundlage
für den dax-konzern adidas vor grundlage
unserer gesetze seine mietzahlungen
einzustellen und das werden letztendlich
auch gerichte überprüfen müssen und ich
bin mir sehr sicher dass das auch dann
die meinung der gerichte sein wird so
wie wir dieses gesetz ausliegen
ihre aktion erinnert aber auch daran
wenn woanders flaggen verbrannt werden
ist das wirklich der richtige weg
gewesen um kritik zu äußern
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass ich
jetzt hier bei ihnen nicht eingeladen
wäre hätte ich mein t shirt nicht
verbrannt oder wollen sie mir da
widersprechen grund war eigentlich
aufmerksamkeit deswegen haben sie ihre
klamotten verbrannt das war perfekt ich
wirklich aus wie werde ich sehr wütend
braucht das verhalten von alters und
weil ich sehr wohl findet dass man sagen
konsumverhalten sein einkaufsverhalten
in bezug auf adidas produkte überdenken
sollte habe ich das gemacht im übrigen
handelt da ist sich hier natürlich um
ein t shirt das wird ihr alt
kleiderspende ungeeignet gewesen dass
ich gebe zu das hatte schon ein paar
löcher mehr adidas produkte habe ich
nämlich nicht besessen
sie werden jetzt trotzdem in den
sozialen medien stark dafür kritisiert
wie gehen sie damit um und haben sie
auch damit gerechnet mit diesen
reaktionen
das sehe ich nicht so wenn ich so sehe
kritik und zustimmung dann würde ich
sagen 90 prozent zustimmung zu seiner
kritik aber das ist als politiker so ich
würde bewusst polarisieren ich will
aufmerksamkeit erzeugen und everybody's
darling ist everybodys depp dieser
spruch stimmt auch jetzt wenn ich mir
das noch zu knapp sei das ein bisschen
mehr nach abneigung gegen diese aktion
aus
als zustimmung was mich aber ganz
besonders an dieser aktion wundert ist
dass doch ihre partei die spd dieses
gesetz das das jetzt für die das möglich
gemacht hat selber durch den bundestag
gebracht hat nur dadurch ist adidas
jetzt die chance gegeben zu sagen sie
wollen nicht mehr zahlen also muss wenn
er ganz direkt sagen haben sie da
offensichtlich einen fehler gemacht
haben wir nicht weil ich so wie adidas
hält sich nicht an das gesetz adidas
legt das gesetz falsch aus wir haben das
gesetz gemacht für notleidende
unternehmen im übrigen besteht die
möglichkeit nur für notleidende
unternehmen mietzahlungen zu stunden die
schuld bleibt dennoch bestehen die
mietzahlung müssen später geleistet
werden aber für adidas gibt das gesetz
keine grundlage er die mietzahlungen die
jetzt werde ich sie zu stoppen das ist
meine meinung und da bin ich auch der
überzeugung dass dieses gesetz ein
richtiges ein wichtiges untergrund des
gesetzes im übrigen lassen sie mich
bitte noch mal zitieren was adidas auf
seiner homepage schreibt
zitat unseres tores bussen seien aber
unser herz ist weit für euch geöffnet
wir als marke stehen weiterhin für teams
beratung gemeinschaft auf in zeiten in
denen wir gerade diese begriffe neu
definieren müssen also wie adidas diese
begriffe neu definiert ich glaube das
hat adidas mit seinem verhalten gezeigt
und ich bin eben der meinung die
konsumenten sollten ihr konsumverhalten
neu definieren einer hat zurück zu dem
gesetz es wird von andreas hardt
ausgelegt heißt aber auch es muss ja
schlupflöcher geben muss es denn jetzt
ausgebessert werden dann nein das heißt
nicht nur weil jemand das gesetz nicht
versteht oder nicht kapiert dass es
deswegen automatisch schlupflöcher gibt
das ist ja eine falsche schlussfolgerung
adidas legt das gesetz so aus wie ja
meinetwegen sieht ja vielleicht sogar
der meinung sind dass es auszulegen ist
und davon kurzfristig zu profitieren ich
bin anderer meinung letztendlich müssen
das dann auch gerichte entscheiden
gerichte haben im übrigen dann auch die
möglichkeit zu überprüfen
befindet sich ein entsprechendes
unternehmen in einer derartigen notlage
das mietzahlungen eben gestoppt werden
können oder nicht das werden dann in
einem rechtsstaat gerichte entscheiden
sollte es dann aber so sein dass
tatsächlich ein schlupfloch bestehen
könnte ich spreche arbeit bewusst im
konjunktiv weil ich der überzeugung bin
dass das nicht der fall ist dann hat der
gesetzgeber und das ist der deutsche
bundestag natürlich die möglichkeit hier
nachzubessern und das würden wir dann
auch tun
das haben sie auch dazu aufgerufen dass
die menschen ihr konsumverhalten vor
allem an die
gegenüber überdenken das ist sozusagen
ein aufruf zum boykott ist das
tatsächlich auch die richtige mitteilung
weiter tausende jobs hängen ja bei
adidas dran wenn man jetzt tatsächlich
diesen konzern boykottieren würde ich
habe es bewusst so formuliert wie es
formuliert habe das ist kann sie dann
noch mal ganz konkret sagen was jetzt
ihrer meinung nach jeder tun sollte
jeder muss für sich
das war immerhin sieben unternehmen dann
soll ich mal unterhalten möchte vielen
dank florian post dass sie hier noch mal
ihre ihr video mit uns besprochen haben
und ihre meinung mit uns geteilt haben
dankeschön wir wollen aber bei diesem
thema bleiben
denn wenn große konzerne wie
beispielsweise adidas es ist aber auch
da ich mein und h&m in dieser corona
krise sagen sie zahlen ihre miete nicht
stellt sich natürlich auch die frage was
wäre wenn das jetzt alles machen würden
wenn also ganz normale mieter jetzt
massenhaft sagen würden nein jetzt
zumindest in diesem moment zahlen wir
keine miete mehr darüber möchte ich
spreche mit lukas siebenkotten präsident
vom deutschen mieterbund und kai
warnecke präsident des
eigentümerverbands haus & grund guten
tag an sie beide danke dass sie hier mit
uns sind die erste frage an sie beide
gerichtet was halten sie davon wenn
konzerne wie adidas und gleich man jetzt
sagen aufgrund dieses neuen gesetzes
zahlen wir erstmal keine miete mehr
das ist eine bodenlose unverschämtheit
um das klar zu sagen denn das gesetz
sieht überhaupt nicht vor dass man die
miete nicht zahlen muss oder soll
sondern es sieht lediglich vor dass wenn
man sie nicht zahlen kann man vor
kündigung geschützt ist also die
zahlungspflicht besteht
selbstverständlich und wenn konzerne die
hohe umsätze machen die hohe gewinne
machen sich dann auf ein gesetz berufen
auf dass sie sich gar nicht berufen
können ist das eine bodenlose
unverschämtheit
hermann egger wie sehen sie das
ja ich sehe das auch so das ist eine
absolute unverschämtheit ist die kommt
allerdings nicht überraschend
das ist letztlich genau die folge die zu
erwarten gewesen ist
nachdem der mieter und genau diese
forderungen aufgestellt hat und die
justizministerinnen dem rat gefolgt ist
stehen wir heute vor dem scherbenhaufen
den wir sehenden auges angerichtet haben
dieser kündigungsschutz war nicht
notwendig weil wir einen wohnraum peter
sauber geschützt sind und es war jetzt
nicht die aufforderung zu nehmen was
adidas jetzt ganz ignorant durchführt es
ist eine katastrophe die da passiert
denn wenn jetzt die zahlungseingänge
ausbleiben wird die deutsche wirtschaft
relativ schnell kollabieren
wir brauchen funktionierende
zahlungsströme denn die kosten der
immobilien laufen gerade bei privaten
kleinen vermietern auch weiter das
signal war eine einzige katastrophe was
vor land gesendet hat und wir hoffen
dass die bundesregierung das zügig
korrigiert
die kritik also nicht nur an den konzern
sondern auch direkt an der politik für
dieses neue gesetz ja absolut
wir haben in deutschland einen
funktionierenden kündigungsschutz und
wenn wir jetzt auch die mieter die
wohnraum bieten zum beispiel darstellen
zurückgreifen
dann wissen wir dass all diejenigen die
nicht zahlungsfähig sind wohngeld
erhalten oder die so genannten kosten
der unterkunft beides schützt davor dass
man überhaupt in zahlungsverzug kommt
weil man nämlich ausreichend geld hatte
und es wäre richtig gewesen von der
politik sicherzustellen dass die kosten
der unterkunft und das wohngeld zügig
und zur not auch ohne große prüfung
ausgezahlt werden damit niemand seine
wohnung verlieren kann es wieder genauso
richtig gewesen dass bei
gewerbetreibenden zu sichern
hier aber ein gesetz vorzuschieben das
an der stellung nur dieses signal gibt
ihr könnt ja machen was ihr wollt ihr
werdet nicht gekündigt und dann
hinterher empört zu sein dass der eine
oder andere das auch genauso ich sage
bewusst missversteht weil es nicht so im
gesetz steht aber weil es eben in der in
der öffentlichen wahrnehmung zum
annehmen aber er kann sich eigentlich
mich beschweren insofern heuchlerisch
von verdammt recht zu sagen sie seien
fertig nehme das der spd in zahnpasten
ich ab der auch dafür bestimmt hat haben
sich denn jetzt schon viele mieter beim
mieterbund gemeldet und gesagt dass sie
ihre miete nicht mehr zu
sein können oder wollen bei den 300
meter vereinen die dem deutschen
mieterbund angeschlossen sind haben sich
etliche mieter inzwischen gemeldet die
vor allen dingen fragen was sie zu tun
haben was mache ich wenn ich meine miete
nicht mehr zahlen kann
und da sagen wir natürlich sie müssen
ihre miete weiter zahlen exakt so steht
es übrigens auch in den gesetzlichen
grundlagen
sie sind nur wenn sie von april bis juni
die miete nicht zahlen können vor
kündigung geschützt und nur das sagt
übrigens das gesetz dass wir sehr
gefordert haben und das unserer ansicht
nach auch gut ist
es bietet ja genau diesen schutz während
große konzerne die nicht zahlen so tun
als würde das gesetz ihnen erlauben
nicht zu zahlen was quatsch ist sie
müssen zahlen und ich gehe auch davon
aus dass einigermaßen vernünftige
menschen in den vorstand warten gibt die
sich überlegen ob sie mit diesem unsinn
nicht aufhören die zahlung in feinen
pass ja gerne was erstaunlich ist ja der
post hat in dem interview ja gerade eben
gesagt das gesetz falsch angewandt und
sagte dann dass gebe die möglichkeit die
miete zu stunden das war das was er
gerade wortwörtlich bei ihnen in der
sendung gesagt hat und es zeige ich dass
herr post das gesetz selbst nicht
verstanden hat dass er mit verabschiedet
hat und dann muss ich doch auch nicht
wundern wenn die menschen in diesem land
das gesetz auch nicht verstehen also ich
kann nur noch mal sagen wir brauchen
jetzt dringend eine unterstützung
derjenigen die miete bezahlen und wenn
dieses gesetz nicht innerhalb der
nächsten woche aufgehoben wird brauchen
wir auch einen traum und diejenigen die
die miete nicht mehr bekommen
insbesondere die kleinen privaten
vermieter für die dass die
altersvorsorge ist zu stützen das muss
jetzt nächste woche dringend auf den weg
gebracht werden deswegen würde ich das
gerne jetzt hier noch einmal klar sagen
die miete entfällt also nicht man kann
sie nur zu einem späteren zeitpunkt
zahlen richtig die miete nicht von dem
gesetz unberührt man muss weiterhin
miete bezahlen das ist genau das was
gleich geblieben ich möchte noch einmal
herum den karten ja sie dürfen gerne
auch ja und damit hat herr dr war ja
klar zum ausdruck gebracht dass das
gesetz gut ist
die miete in der tat weiter zahlen man
ist nur vor kündigung in den nächsten
monaten geschützt deswegen muss ich das
gesetz geändert werden soll das muss
adidas und co auf die finger gehauen
werden das ist das entscheidende
was genau raten sie denn jetzt beiden
zum einen vermietern als auch mietern in
dieser situation wo es anscheinend auch
sehr viele offene fragen dazu gibt wie
dieses gesetz jetzt angewendet werden
soll und angewendet wird wir haben
vorgeschlagen dass man einen fonds
bildet der hingeht und kleinen mietern
und kleinen vermietern hilft wir sind
daran interessiert dass die kleinen
vermieter nicht diejenigen sind die bei
der ganzen geschichte unter die räder
kommen ein solcher von muss gebildet
werden aber nicht unter aufhebung des
gesetzes sondern als unterstützung und
zusätzliche maßnahme damit dieses gesetz
seine wirkung in richtiger weise erzielt
haneke das gesetz oder der vw ja gar
nicht notwendig wenn es weiter
mietzahlungen gebe jetzt wo er
tatsächlich erleben dass der eine oder
andere unter berufung auf dieses im
gesetz dass ich immer noch nicht für
richtig halte der sieben konnten
tatsächlich die mietzahlung einstellt
brauchen wir jetzt den rettungsfonds für
private vermieter wir haben die
situation dass große unternehmen durch
die kfw-mittel beschützt sind wir haben
auch die situation dass klar an
gewerbetreibende bestürzt sind wir haben
auch die situation dass mieter geschützt
sind
lediglich die privaten vermietern
bleiben hier völlig auf der strecke
während sie weiterhin die kosten tragen
müssen
sie kümmert sich darum dass die heizung
weiterläuft das weiter wasser bezogen
werden kann
das sind also kosten die der vermieter
jeden einzelnen tag packard gleichgültig
auf ein geschäft geöffnet ist oder auch
gleichgültig ob eure wohnung bewohnt ist
oder nicht und deswegen brauchen wir und
da stehe ich an siebenkotten
ausnahmsweise mal zu das haben wir von
anfang an so fordert dringend einen
fonds der die privaten vermieter
unterstützt aber ein gesetz dass man
nicht braucht und dass modifikationen er
führt haben wir auch nicht und deswegen
muss aufgehoben werden
vielen dank an sie beides gibt also noch
immer sehr viel gesprächsbedarf was
dieses gesetz angeht und generell wie es
jetzt weitergeht sowohl aus vermieter
als auch mieter sich in dieser corona
krise vielen dank nochmal dass sie beide
teil unserer sendung waren